yes i do
i think it does not only say that but he
went on to say that
they're very good people on both sides
again come on
people walk around in a governor's
driveway with
assault rifles and wave flags i mean
they should be this is something to be
concerned about
and they saw what the head of the fbi
said a couple days ago
he said the greatest terrorist threat in
america is from
white supremacists why can't the
president just say
stop stop stop stop
and we will pursue you if you don't so
stop
no i don't comment on his childhood
remarks
i didn't hear what you said
it's despicable it's despicable so
beneath the office of the presidency
and the american people are sick and
tired of it they know who this man is
it's got to stop
it's not only this is one of the finest
questions i've ever dealt with
this is a person who is ready on day one
to be president united states of america
this is a person that's more integrity
in the little finger than most people
have in their whole body
and the idea it's obvious he cannot he
has
great difficulty dealing with strong
women very difficult
he did a great job and by the way
just like he said that that
the vice president won last night just
like he won his debate
they're both winners
he's delusional
well yeah it's not surprising i mean
i'll ask a rhetorical question none of
you can answer were any of you surprised
i mean who knows look we agreed to three
debates
back in the summer this has been going
on since the early 90s
first debate first the person second
debate
town hall format third debate first to
person
we set the dates i'm sticking with the
dates i'm showing up
i'll be there and in fact if he shows up
fine if he doesn't find
absolutely positively we will commit
no neither one i'm answering think about
think about it neither one of them
answered i've watched how
last night watching the debate started
to take my eye off the fly but
watching the debate i found i shouldn't
be so sarcastic but
what i found was i found him that
i don't know whether he was afraid to
take a position that he knew he should
take
because it would be contrary to the
president's or whether he really
believes it too
but you know what was it stand down and
stand by or whatever i mean
come on this is this is just wrong the
rest of the world
look some of you have covered
international politics before
the rest of the world's looking at us
it's an embarrassment
it's a pure embarrassment gotta
they'll know my opinion of court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question y'all and i
don't blame you for asking me
but you know the moment i answered that
question the headline in every one of
your papers
will be about that other than
other than focusing on what's happening
now
the election has begun there's never
been a court appointment once an
election begun what
four million or so people have already
voted
they're denying the american people the
one shot
they have under constitutional law to be
able to have their input
and that is picking the person who can
name who they
happy to lay out in detail what i'm
going to do after that
if i'm the president if i'm not the
president
he gets to pick it thank you
all right